et bien voilà dimanche nous allons voter
pour le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et je pense que pour la
plupart d'entre nous nous savons pour
qui
nous envisageons de voter mais est ce
que nous avons toujours pourquoi nous
allons voter je dirai ce que nous savons
ce que celui qui sera élu président de
la république pour sept ans par nos
suffrages va faire du pouvoir
considérable que nous allons lui confier
est-ce que nous avons pris le temps
d'examiner et de comparer les projets
des candidats
alors je sais bien certains se disent
après tout tous ces projets se
ressemblent plus ou moins bien
évidemment mais on peut dire ça de tous
par exemple toutes les automobiles se
ressemblent plus ou moins et est ce que
nous choisissons notre voiture
les yeux bandés et bien le choix d'un
président c'est au moins aussi important
que celui d'une automobile
car de quoi s'agit-il mais il s'agit
tout simplement de savoir si au cours
des années qui viennent la france va
devenir un un pays minuscule ou bien si
la france va devenir l'un des moteurs
d'une europe qui aura fait sa place dans
le monde
alors évidemment tout cela dépend très
largement de vous de nous de nous tous
de l'énergie de chacun de nous mais cela
dépend aussi dans une très large mesure
des choix qui seront faits pendant sept
ans par notre président alors quel choix
franchement je crois qu'on a pris moins
de temps pour s'en préoccuper que pour
suivre l'évolution des courbes des
sondages ou comparer les campagnes de
pub les sondages ils sont là en principe
pour nous éclairer
mais je me demande s'ils n'ont pas fini
par nous aveugler et la publicité elle
est là pour nous parler mais je crois
qu'elle a fini par nous assourdir on
peut s'arrêter à la publicité et à
l'emballage quand il s'agit d'acheter
c'est pas une poudre de lessive
mais quand il s'agit du président de la
république il faut peut-être
s'intéresser davantage aux produits si
j'ose dire c'est à dire à l'homme et à
son projet quant aux sondages
l'élection présidentielle ce n'est pas
le tiercé dimanche quand nous serons
chacun d'entre nous seul face à
nous-mêmes dans l'isoloir
il ne s'agira pas de voter pour celui
que privilégie tel ou tel institut de
sondage
il s'agira de voter pour celui en qui on
a confiance
pour l'aider à gagner en ce qui me
concerne dimanche je vais voter pour
raymond barre parce qu'il m'a convaincu
parce que j'ai confiance en lui
la confiance est un sentiment personnel
que j'éprouve peut-être le partagerai
vous j'espère qu'il va vous convaincre
il va répondre aux questions de daniel
grandclément en tout cas je vous demande
pendant quelques minutes de l'écouter en
vous disant que sept ans
ça vaut bien quelques minutes
d'attention bonsoir monsieur bah on soit
nous allons essayer de garder
l'attention des téléspectateurs comme
nous le conseille
dominique baudis vous terminer fort
cette campagne terminée en battant
sèchement ce la dernière ligne droite
dans la dernière ligne droite il faut
j'en suis convaincu convaincre persuadé
mériter la confiance alors l'émission de
ce soir est basée et moi vous avez
choisi comme thème les défis se posent à
la france en france et dans le monde et
le premier de ces défis pour vous c'est
l'éducation alors je vous propose de
voir tout de suite l'un des témoignages
que vous avez vous même choisi pour
illustrer dont ce problème
l'éducation je suis institutrice à
marseille depuis 26 ans dans l'école
publique et notamment neuf ans dans un
quartier très difficile de marseille
j'ai deux filles elles ont suivi une
partie de leur scolarité dans ce
quartier sans problème
j'ai fréquenté moi même les deux écoles
laïques et privés j'estime qu'il est
fondamental que les parents gardent ce
choix de mettre leurs enfants dans
l'école publique ou privée je crois
qu'on ne résoudra pas le problème de
l'enseignement en france si on fait
l'économie de réforme de réformes de
structure je sais bien que beaucoup
d'hommes politiques hésitent à en parler
mais moi je suis persuadé qu'il faut
repasser par là et qu'il faut remettre
en cause l'idée d'un système unique la
gestion centralisée nationale qui
n'existe d'ailleurs nulle part ailleurs
dans le monde et en particulier je ne
crois pas que la solution puisse
consistait à augmenter globalement les
crédits l'éducation nationale parce que
c'est coûtera certainement plus cher à
la nation mais ça rendra pas le système
plus rationnel alors premier point le
pluralisme
qu'il est sérieusement menacée
aujourd'hui il n'est plus menacée
puisque les français sont venus des
chivet et à 2 millions dans les rues de
paris pour défendre la liberté de
l'enseignement mais bien qu'ils ne
soient plus menacées
je pense qu'il serait utile que par voie
de référendum la liberté de
l'enseignement soit inscrite dans la
constitution et c'est mon intention
si je suis ému deuxième point la réforme
faut-il encore une réforme il ne s'agit
pas d'une de ces réformes comme celles
que l'on fait tous les deux ans tous les
trois ans il s'agit d'une rénovation de
notre système éducatif
une remarque j'ai confiance dans les
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
de l'enseignement privé
je crois qu'il ne faut pas critiquer des
hommes et des femmes qui ont une tâche
difficile et qu'ils accomplissent avec
beaucoup de confiance et c'est avec eux
qu'il faudra rénover notre système
les principes sont simples il faut
décentraliser parce que le système comme
il a été dit est trop centralisée
il faut adapter les programmes
d'enseignement et en particulier les
ouvrir sur l'entreprise et sur la vie et
en troisième lieu il faut abandonner
cette attitude française qui consistait
à considérer qu'il y à une filière noble
qui l'enseignement classique et une
filière secondaire qui l'enseignement
technologique
nous avons besoin de demain de jouer la
carte de l'intelligence dans tous les
domaines de l'utiliser la matière grise
dans tous les champs du savoir et de la
connaissance
eh bien il faut que nous mettions sur le
même plan aussi bien la formation que
nous appelons classique traditionnelle
et la formation technologique et
l'apprentissage qui doivent correspondre
aux aspirations de ceux qui sont
orientés vers des choses plus pratiques
de la vie deuxième défi la révolution
technologique la recherche propose de
voir d'écouter le professeur montagnier
besoin d'une politique de la recherche
cohérente et résolu notre civilisation a
besoin de la recherche aussi bien de la
recherche fondamentale que de la
recherche appliquée l'exemple de la
découverte du virus du sida montre
l'importance de la recherche
fondamentale mais les efforts de la
france en matière de recherche sont
insuffisants
relativement par exemple au
développement qui existe dans les autres
grands pays industriels comme les
etats-unis le japon l'allemagne
d'autre part la recherche privée et très
insuffisamment développée elle est aussi
importante que la recherche publique
c'est pourquoi avec beaucoup de mes
collègues j'ai des inquiétudes pour
l'avenir et je voudrais demander à
monsieur bart quelle est la politique
qu'il entend mener dans ce domaine
s'il est élu président de la république
la question vous est posée éducation
recherche c'est toujours joué la carte
de l'intelligence nous avons une
recherche nous pouvons être fiers
ce que celle trouvée sur montanier pour
le sida est unanimement reconnu et
respecté dans le monde entier
mais c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas tous les
moyens nécessaires nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de ressources mises à la
disposition de la recherche cédantes et
a demandé 2 % notre produit intérieur
brut à l'heure actuelle alors que ces 2
8% chez nos principaux concurrents
je propose que d'ici mieux d'ici cinq
ans une législature est lié et 3% de
notre produit intérieur brut qu'ils
soient consacrés à la recherche je
propose en second lieu qu'il y est un
plan de recrutement régulier de jeunes
chercheurs
il faut que les jeunes ait à la
recherche et il faut en troisième lieu
organiser les relations entre la
recherche et les entreprises petites et
moyennes entreprises surtout de telle
sorte que la recherche puisse irrigué
notre vie économique et à porter les
idées pour les produits nouveaux et les
processus de production nouveau voilà je
crois les grandes lignes d'une politique
de la recherche
troisième défi la culture voici ce qu'en
dit philippe de villiers je crois qu'il
faut que pour le rayonnement de la
culture française nous fassions trois
choses d'abord il faut faire le marché
commun de l'image pour avoir plus de
qualité plus d'émissions plus de
téléfilm plus de dessins animés qu'ils
soient d'origine européenne est
d'origine française
la deuxième chose a trait à la politique
du patrimoine pour que nos monuments nos
musées nos lieux de mémoire deviennent
de véritables lieux de vie et puis il
faut que nous fassions grande politique
d'éducation artistique une heure
d'histoire de l'art dans nos écoles pour
que
les petits français demain apprennent à
connaître leur pays le pays des
chefs-d'oeuvre et qu'ils apprennent à
aimer la france
tout cela semble assez facile à dire est
intéressant mais très difficile à faire
monsieur ben c'est difficile à faire
mais nous devons avoir une politique de
la culture
je dis bien une politique la culture
elles n'ont pas une politisation de la
culture comme nous l'avons vu sous le
septennat de monsieur muzion du moins
dans les cinq premières années de ce
septennat
je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit et
philippe de villiers j'ajoute que des
moyens doivent être données dans le
domaine de la culture
et c'est toi c'est évidemment aux
municipalités le berne toulouse peut le
dire aux régions aux départements de
s'en occuper
il faut que l'état y contribuer et les
socialistes avaient promis que le budget
de la culture passerait à 1 % du budget
global
cela n'a pas été réalisé et bien
donnons-nous comme objectif sur les cinq
ans qui viennent d'accorder 1 % du
budget à la culture
alors pour l'instant on est un petit peu
resté en france ma famille aussi des
défis qui se posent à la france à son
nom d'alors lesquels ou penser auquel il
y a à mon avis trois grands défis
le défi de la paix le défi de l'europe
est le défi du développement et que la
paix d'abord vous n'êtes pas très chauds
partisans du désarmement nom ne dit pas
cela je suis partisan du désarmement
mais je ne suis pas partisan de
n'importe quel des armements
je suis mitterrand veut faire croire
qu'il est l'homme du désarmement
je rappelle que dès 1978
monsieur giscard d'estaing avait saisi
nos partenaires des problèmes du
désarmement
ce qu'il faut c'est un désarmement
équilibré qui ne soit pas simplement un
désarmement nucléaire qui soient des
armements dans le domaine nucléaire dans
le domaine chimique et dans le domaine
des forces conventionnelles et il faut
que ce soit les superpuissances qui
commence à désarmer parce que ce sont
elles qui accumule les armements
lorsqu'elles auront donné la preuve
qu'elles veulent la paix en les duisans
leurs arsenaux alors nous nous pourrons
regarder quel sera notre contribution au
désarmement
mais d'ici là restons vigilants de
baissons pas la garde
ils ont commencé déjà les à m elle
serait uniquement uniquement avait
l'option zéro et l'option double zéro je
crois que cela conduit à faiblir plutôt
la sécurité de l'europe qu'à donner le
sentiment d'un désarmement eux
normal d'un désarmement qui aille dans
la bonne direction
deuxième défi l'europe et vous aimez les
choses concrètes et vous souhaitez que
nous passions la parole à monsieur
baudis car vous êtes maire de toulouse
et c'est peut-être à toulouse qu'il est
la concrétisation les plus évidentes de
ce que peut réussir l'europe avec les
avions toulouse est une grande ville de
france mais c'est aussi maintenant une
grande capitale technologiques
européennes avec en particulier la
construction aéronautique et les
programmes spatiaux et chacun sait le
rôle qui a été jouée par raymond barre
pour accompagner le programme airbus et
le programme ariane alors à toulouse
nous réussissons pour deux raisons nous
jouons sur la la matière grise
à défaut de matières premières et puis
nous avons appris à travailler en équipe
entre européens et ça c'est plus une
réussite finalement il y en a eu une
grande réussite difficile à faire ça oui
mais il ya 25 ans je m'occupe d'affaires
européenne et l'europe
il faut l'a démontré par des
réalisations concrètes comme celle dont
bodicien de nous parler qu'est ce que
nous avons à faire maintenant nous avons
à faire le grand marché intérieur au 1er
janvier 1993
préparons nous y consacrons si nos
efforts nous avons à faire l'europe
monétaire parce que nous ne pouvons pas
laisser le système mondial
sur le plan monétaire dans un tel état
d'instabilité
nous avons en troisième lieu à faire
l'europe technologique nous l'avons
commencée et ensuite nous avons à faire
l'europe politique c'est à dire l'europe
de la sécurité et de la défense c'est
dans ces quatre domaines qu'il faut
avancer par des réalisations concrètes
cessons de dire l'europe l'europe
l'europe mais agissons troisième grand
défi la coopération et vous avez choisi
d'écouter le témoignage d'un jeune
coopérant kate et à djibouti
mon service militaire à djibouti dans le
cadre de la coopération
et c'était une expérience très
enrichissante ça permet de s'ouvrir un
peu sur l'extérieur ça permet de voir ce
qu il yad autres et
comment vivent les gens vais réellement
le sang contient deux grands grand
besoin que la france at elle un rôle à
jouer et surtout les jeunes coopérants
français ont un rôle à jouer dans le
développement économique des pays comme
la france à des dérives pas trop cher la
coopération non sur un goût de pas cher
dites vous bien que nous avons tout
intérêt à ce que le monde en
développement puissent accroître ses
ressources les pays en développement
sont pour nous d'excellents clients
mais il n'y a pas simplement que le
problème financier le problème
mercantile il faut bien voir que la
grande querelle du 21e siècle sera la
querelle du développement c'est à dire
la querelle de l'homme il ne peut pas y
avoir de disparités croissantes entre
pays développés et pays en voie de
développement et il faut que la france
apparaisse dans ce domaine j'ai eu un
mot de conclusion c'était un compliment
ce que vous venez de dire mais ma
conclusion démission ma conclusion elle
est très simple une france forte dans
une europe puissante une france forte
par la formation des hommes par
l'éducation par la recherche par
l'investissement par la culture une
europe unie et puissante
une europe unie et puissante dans le
domaine de la technologie dans le
domaine de la mener dans le domaine de
la sécurité
voilà l'objectif que nous devons
poursuivre merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission
merci de l'avoir regardé